[Musique]
là bas
il ya des arbres durant des nuages
[Musique]
de l'air frais qui fouette le visage
si je dors mon chez moi
[Musique]
c'est pour ça que gérer la mort
là bas
il faut démasquer souliers pour 1
[Musique]
mais ya pas trop de risques à mon âge
citons attestation puis là
le monoxyde ouvre les bras
[Musique]
c'est pour ça que j'irai là bas
n'y va pas
[Musique]
y'a plus de pain plus de beurre c'est le
carnage
tu vas devoir battre pour du fromage
et vu ta gueule tu gagneras pas
[Musique]
[ __ ] reste chez toi tu as déjà quand
vous
ça grince
[Musique]
antilles
ça fait deux jours entiers du col acabit
[Musique]
oué
si je pense pas qu'un jeu le rac 1
[Musique]
s'il ya plus de pq c'est pas grave c'est
moore a écrit plantes ouvrage il est si
visionnarts parfois
c'est lui qui tous nous sauvera je veux
aller au parc est aussi des maris va pas
au restaurant aux [ __ ] et où ce temps
là bas je suis pas tant aristote de sacy
crois moi serait peut-être survivre un
puissant je crois pas je te dirai
peut-être là maintenant je serai chez
moi j'aime passer du temps avec toi il
ya plein de gens dehors je les vois les
tarbais toi et moi ça sera là bas ou 20
le t71 les bodegas et moi tout ça
avec rené seul
chez moi c'était bien jusqu'à quel point
j'ai vraiment un poisson chat et un
commentaire to war et moi je me suis
déjà mort les cadences
matt pokora mal ne nous a pas laissé le
choix tant que choix
était
et c'est moi
d'ici là
là
[Musique]
véronique et davina